we start with china where dramatic
lockdowns of major cities in an attempt
to stick to a zero covet strategy is
leading to massive consequences for the
world is the disruption of the global
supply chain for the people of china
it's about lives turned upside down more
lockdowns and testing and intense
surveillance
residents in beijing have gotten used to
this
mass testing is china's standard
reaction to the slightest covet outbreak
in addition to targeted lockdowns and
lengthy quarantines
but these cues seen over the past week
have been exceptionally long
millions had to get tested following an
outbreak related to a bar with over 350
cases
that's a lot by chinese standard
now the local government says it has
everything under control
after eight days of arduous battle in
the concerted efforts of the people of
the whole city the effect of quick and
decisive measures has been shown
the epidemic situation related to
heaven's supermarket bar is easing
viewed by the highly contagious omicron
variant the broader outbreak in beijing
has already lasted for more than 50 days
with many people staying home and some
businesses closed the city's commerce
has been disrupted
a price china is willing to pay so far
at least as it pursues the so-called
zero-covet policy and strives to stamp
out the disease
many residents are ready to go along
with the strategy as they feel the
alternative could be worse
i'm worried because i previously stayed
for a while in shanghai
the epidemic there started with a small
store and nobody thought that the
situation would be so severe
now beijing is in similar trouble to
shanghai
shanghai is slowly recovering after a
two-month hard lockdown
with visitors once again able to enjoy
some of the tourist sites it has to
offer
such as the newly reopened disney town
but the city is still far from normality
since any new outbreaks could change the
life shanghai people just started to
enjoy again
joining us in the studio is chengjia ian
associate professor of political science
at the national university of singapore
thanks for joining the program
thank you
i want to start by looking at how much
chinese citizens will put up with
people are very stressed over there and
we've seen bits of protest here and
there
right so i mean it's of course a big
question over how stressed and how upset
people i mean we've seen sporadic
protests here and there
over food over
exiting of uh
cordoned off areas so that i think
suggests a certain level of frustration
among the people who've been
essentially sort of locked down uh to
keep them to maintain the covet zero
policy but i guess the big question is
how widespread all of this is how
coordinated
a lot of this is i mean there is seems
to be some coordination of frustration
online but whether that translates
elsewhere i think is something that's
really difficult to see from the outside
or even for that matter in china given
the
restrictions on
the free flow of information there but
certainly frustration is building up
so what's your take on how sustainable
this policy will be
i think ultimately it's not going to be
sustainable on the basis of the economy
it's not so much what people think or
feel because the chinese state has a
real ability to put down any protests it
doesn't like um but i think where things
get much trickier is if the chinese
economy slows to a pace where the
leaders find it to be alarming then they
may make some adjustment that having
been said xi jinping has sort of put his
own personal stamp on the covet zero
policy and going up into the
20th party congress that may mean any
adjustment may be difficult because i
don't think she wants to see be seen to
be wrong or to be weak
and um i mean so she kind of owns this
i'm curious
is the government explaining themselves
i mean most analysts outside the country
know this is connected to xi jinping's
retention of political power but what is
beijing telling people
so it seems to be telling people that
it's necessary
is necessary and that's really the line
that they've been pushing uh in addition
to to the vaccination although i think
you know
the degree to which uh all this is
you know containable the mess the
messages are containable i think um
we'll rest on you know how much people
if eventually in china get a sense of
what's going on
outside and also how how much they're
hurting economically because ultimately
i think for the current regime it comes
down to you know what people are feeling
in their sort of ability to get on with
their daily lives especially their
ability to work to get jobs i mean some
of the reporting is that um unemployment
um income all that is under quite a lot
of stress so i think you know it comes
down to whether uh the
any sort of rhetoric is able to overcome
these very realistic pressures that
people face which i think will be
difficult uh once the you know pressure
really comes yeah
yeah i mean it's interesting because one
justification one imagines is the
chinese state pointing to the 1 million
deaths in the united states and how
the chinese state certainly has not
allowed that to happen to their citizens
lastly you are in singapore so how is
china's policy
impacting the region
so the big thing with uh china's policy
seems to be the slowdown in its economy
and given that uh the southeast asia and
singapore included
in there is that our economies are very
much intertwined with uh that of uh the
prc as well as actually the rest of the
world but uh what happens is that what
one big part of that uh economic
relationship seems to be under stress
seems to be more sealed off from before
i mean that obviously applause affects
supply uh that obviously then adds
pressure on inflation so
uh there's that big concern there
although i suppose some people are quite
taken by this claim that the prc has
managed to keep deaths down but of
course that's clearly very important but
it's not the only part of the story
especially since um for people who are
outside of china who i think have opened
up and figured that well opening up and
getting the economy started may be
something that is um pretty important as
well
ian thank you so much for joining us as
always